[Music]
Oh what is going on YouTube check it out
pimp giggle there are a lot of long
topics that I love to talk about but
there are a few that I'm extremely
passionate about one of them is about
bullying for those of you who do not
know I hate bullies I hate bullies I
don't like being bullied I don't like
the fact that people get bullied so I'm
here to talk about that today there are
a lot of you out there who get bullied
who I feel they either don't know how to
deal with it or you guys don't have a
voice for yourself well guess what my
friends were being bugged out there your
big brother Davis o is here to help you
out so you already know what it is
LG awesome baby let's get a neck out
[Music]
anybody that bully somebody is a little
[ __ ] that's why I said it I mean I'm
give a bird no that's why I'm telling
you little cross-eyed crusty-ass mother
[ __ ] the only reason why you a bully
somebody is probably because it makes
you feel better about your sorry-ass
existence no because we all know you
will never pick on somebody that would
fight back because your hash stupid and
I'll see your head ugly almost you I
will jump off a bridge face-first into a
pile of glass you sack of [ __ ] matter of
fact I hope you had like some kind of
amazing telling like you could play the
violin really well so I can smash your
finger so you can never play again [ __ ]
oh and excuse me mr. bully hurry know
what you think you're thinking guess
what David you would never say this to
my face I grew up in a black preacher
supply store with women with weave
complexes do you think I'm scared of a
[ __ ] bully
well karate chop the [ __ ] out your face
y'all ever notice that most bullies are
kind of stupid
they usually don't like too much going
on up here but like too hot despondent
over lollipop it's on my friends if you
want being bullied I'm gonna give you an
easy solution to get away from what when
they try to attack you what you should
do is throw them a real quick math pause
and see if they can figure it out well
looky what we have here nerd [ __ ] shut
up what's two plus two what two plus 22
that right we're all thinking but also
you got to realize that half the time
they make fun of you it's usually the
same [ __ ] over and over again for
example here's a joke that every single
[ __ ] heard when they were drinking at
the bottom family hey Shamu save some
water from the whales because they're
fishes right oh where the shambles are
saltwater man we'll just to let you know
ya dumbass so how did I deal with
getting
when I was a kid to be honest with you
don't do what I did because I'm an
[ __ ] and I've been talking like this
is how the kid like people will clown on
me with fictional jokes but I will come
back with some truth hey damn it you're
so fat that when you jump the earth
shakes hey Timmy your daddy was cheating
on your mom yesterday hey here's another
bit of advice that some people may or
may not agree with but i'ma tell you
this straight-up some of you who get
bullied you're gonna have to go ahead
and stand up for yourself at some point
or another I'm not telling you here to
get into a physical fight or even to get
loud or get your ass whooped but what I
am saying at a certain point you're
going to have to learn to stand on your
own two feet and stand up for yourself
and not always cower in fear I'm pretty
sure that by now if you have been
bullied you have heard this saying well
if you don't pay attention to them it'll
go away bad stupid stupid bullies are
like having your zipper down on your
pants like you can't just leave it alone
it'll go away you got to pull the [ __ ]
up be a strong individual and stand your
ground now that does not mean that you
should fight them or even do anything to
piss them off but what that does mean is
that you shouldn't be a little [ __ ]
personally grown up as a kid from where
I'm from and people didn't respect you
you had to earn it but then again some
of y'all kids live in the ghetto so I
know what you're gonna ask well what if
they try to beat me up and jump me for
no reason
I already the vlog on this number one
get the braces off your legs and run
Forrest run
number two blow your rape whistle and if
you don't have one what a function rape
whistle number three if well if you
didn't do number two then you know you
just might have to take one for the team
my bad dawg I don't know the same here's
a little bit of honest advice every
single bullet that I've known growing up
they used to pump people for no reason
they're a bunch of losers now look just
think about it they might be cool now
but in the future when they're homeless
with no teeth with like a crack pile up
their ass you know with the little
mother baby tattoo on arm you're gonna
win my friends just like you growing up
I was bullied too and I hated it I do
not accept it and I do not
and for those of you out there that see
somebody else getting bullied and you
watch guess what mother [ __ ] you want
just as bad as them if you can sit and
watch another human being get ridiculed
and bullied and still be able to sleep
at night my friend you know better I'm
gonna say this again but for those of
you right now who are being bullied on
are constantly in this state where you
feel horrible because these people don't
trip
I guarantee something I put this on my
life that your life will get better if
later on tonight I asked you to be my
girlfriend right and in the future if
you work hard and be the great person
that you are
damn it as a text big brother David slow
that David so I just [ __ ] the mom in
oh and if you're a bully and your thug
guess what
I'm sorry odd please don't hurt me